next one
and this one is about characters and uh
susan hill had asked basically like how
to form a character
in your act
um
so
it takes i think the key is it just
takes practice
with characters especially if she's
talking about new characters or like
characters like
her own character probably like maybe
like
doing act outs i don't know that's all
she really said is like doing yeah
okay if it's that then it just takes
practice
right like
it takes practice of going into that
character
um on stage
and you know when i do act outs you know
i do act outs of my dad and i do act out
to my mom i do act outs of like
i've gotta act out of like what i think
white people sound like i do act outs of
what i think somebody that looks like
joel sound like yeah what do people
sound like you know like white people
like what you don't do the the nerdy
white people
i do miners upper class like very
hoity-toity like um
[Music]
and there's also the
other levels of it right like the you
know
not that there's different levels of
white but you know there is there's 50
shades of white for sure
but yeah so i think it just takes
practice i think that's the key with
characters it's just practice it but
also remember
that
you just don't go into the character the
character has to be a part of the joke
don't just say here's an in my
impression of
this that doesn't really work like just
on a stand-up stage um versus you know
my dad sounds like
uh
donald trump every once in a while and
then you go into the trump voice but
saying what your dad would say like
that's character development
yeah i think it can be helpful because
it's scary like i mean at least for me
everyone has different skills in like
their comedy arsenal but like
characters and act outs or something i'm
still and i want to be more intentional
about in this kind of this
next chapter of my career of like
getting a little more animated doing
more characters and voices or stuff
because for the longest it's just like
i'm so focused on the words and the
delivery is kind of it comes second to
that
so what's helped me to ease into that is
like doing personal characters not like
trying to do an impression which i'm now
working on a joel osteen impression
which is
um
which is all right you know
it's all right
it's an all right impression won't he
really he has risen unlike my social
media following after posting it
but um
mostly it's been like making fun of like
my family or doing my own like country
voice and things and so i think starting
from a personal place will help you to
develop characters
yeah that's solid